elle était fermée depuis octobre dernier
at on enfin rouvert dans les yvelines à
les terrasses sont rouvertes depuis
aujourd'hui 1 ce midi à il y en a
certains qui n'ont pas hésité à venir
dès aujourd'hui dès les premières heures
pour passer un petit temps en terrasse
maël bah oui c'est ça on profite un peu
entre deux examens
de venir soutenir un peu les restaurants
les bars on est du métier nous aussi
encore en apprentissage jusqu'à la fin
de l'année
mais on trouve sur important et puis
après c'est sympa de se retrouver avec
les amis autour d'une bonne guerre mais
elle est ce que c'était important pour
vous aussi d'être ici aujourd'hui
ben oui évidemment c'est qu'être à table
avec les copains c'est toujours un
moment qui est sympa ça nous manquait à
tous c'était un peu aussi notre endroit
où tout le monde se réunissent et après
les cours donc sec de retrouver sa
maintenance et c'est important et aussi
pour les restaurateurs du coup de se
relancer un peu dans l'activité je pense
que c'est c'est bon pour tout le monde
alors ce midi ils seront nombreux malgré
à la météo ici on prévoit environ 80
personnes en extérieur si la météo le
permet et 60 personnes si il fait
mauvais nous allons justement rencontré
le gérant de cette institution qui est
présenté ici à saint quentin en yvelines
depuis 26 ans franck alors franck est ce
que c'était important pour vous d'ouvrir
aujourd'hui je crois que vous en aviez
très envie bonjour michael bay et oui
c'était important parce qu'on a tous
soif
même si la météo n'est pas des plus
clémentes c'est comme en bretagne
un coup je te vois un coup je te vois
pas où une autre situation il fait beau
plusieurs fois par jour donc oui c'est
important pour tout le monde et puis
pour le dans la tête surtout comment ça
s'est passé pour l'organisation c'était
compliqué à mettre en place non pas plus
compliqué que ça mais bon évidemment
c'est une réouverture 1 6 mois ferme et
il ya des automatismes qui sont perdus
des choses arnett et donc mon l'a fait
au mieux on pense à cueillir pas mal de
gens je pense que ça à venir déjà 11h30
on a déjà un petit peu de monde donc
voilà je vous espérez pour les
prochaines semaines déjà avoir le
maximum de monde pour la réouverture
définitive le 9 juin avec du public en
intérieur évidemment du monde mais
surtout que ça se passe bien voilà qu'on
soit un peu dans la fête et que la fête
soit pas gâchée par des mauvaises choses
et puis évidemment que ça y est au plus
vite pour qu'on puisse réouvrir à
l'intérieur si la météo n'est pas là
merci beaucoup franck en tout cas on l'a
compris à beaucoup de monde sur les
terrasses malgré une météo capricieuse
on espère que la météo s'améliorant dans
les prochaines semaines évidemment pour
avoir un maximum de monde ici sur ce
bistrot du théâtre à saint quentin en
yvelines
moi je vais un petit peu profité et
boire un petit verre